as expected the national football league
investigating deshaun watson in the
aftermath of multiple lawsuits filed
alleging assault
during massage encounters attorney tony
busby
posting on social media the letter
clearly marked confidential
by lisa friel of the league office
explaining that number one the
investigation is launched number two
they would like the alleged victims to
cooperate with the investigation that's
one of the great flaws and weaknesses of
the nfl's in-house
investigative process miles there's no
way they can compel anyone
to cooperate and the fact that the
letter was placed on social media by
busby who has been very very active on
instagram
with his involvement in these cases
i suspect that that he will encourage
his clients to
cooperate with the national football
league unless of course there's a
settlement i don't know if it's too late
for that
but if there's a settlement with an
agreement to not talk about it which is
perfectly legitimate
it happens all the time there's
confidentiality provisions and
settlements
there'd be no power for the nfl to talk
to these people there'd be nothing the
nfl could do
to deshaun watson and with nine now
that are signed up by tony busby and
busby has said that
seven lawsuits have been filed we've
seen three of them
there's gonna be a press conference
today they all flow from
these allegations of some level or
degree of misconduct and there are
varying levels and degrees of alleged
misconduct
during private massage sessions and
miles
as sims and i were saying yesterday the
takeaway for
every other professional athlete or
anyone who has any
assets that could be at risk do not put
yourself
in these positions where it ultimately
could be
your word against someone else's word
with no witnesses
and no way to prove that your word is
the true word
yes exactly and that is why i think a
lot of teams
have masseuses set up in the training
room right there
are ways that this can happen through
the team
and so that's part of why because it
helps
keep everybody protected from the
masseuse
you know who is in a situation that
could potentially become
uncomfortable just based on the way that
professional athletes need to keep their
bodies maintained
and then from the athletes standpoint
where you know you are getting the
protection of yes
this is all above board and this because
it is you know
provided by the team um there is no way
that something can possibly
be misinterpreted so i think you're
absolutely right you have to make sure
you know that you are protecting
yourself
all parties need to make sure of that um
so that something
like this cannot happen where there is
some sort of alleged misconduct
and look the reality is
the more total alleged victims there are
the harder
it is to convince the average person
with with no predispositions with no
opinions with no
knowledge you just hear the numbers
and at a certain point i don't know what
the over under is but at a certain point
the numbers over power the individual
denial denial denial denial denial at a
certain point there's
too many to get the average person
to say anything other than oh that's
this isn't good
now that doesn't mean he did it and it's
possible
it's possible at this point that he will
prevail in every single one of these
cases and again some cases
stronger than others as it relates to
the alleged misconduct the first lawsuit
filed
you could read it and you could say even
if all this is true
what what's the assault uh the the
second lawsuit had some of that
that same element to it the third
lawsuit a little more troubling
at least based on the allegations now
whether or not those allegations can be
proven
that remains to be seen and what it
comes down to
it will be the testimony of the shah
assuming this goes all the way through
to a trial any of these
any summer all of these nine if they're
finally
all nine filed apparently seven have
been filed and there's a press
conference today where tony busby's
gonna
talk about the case and give out copies
of the complaints and show some text
messages more on that in a second
but you have the testimony of deshaun
watson the testimony of the alleged
victim
presumably no other witnesses to any of
these encounters
and then the only objective evidence the
only undeniable evidence
any text messages or other digital
communications between
the masseuses and desean watson so
last night there were two such messages
chains of messages released by tony
busby
and my reaction was if this is the best
you got
these messages aren't going to help you
if anything they're going to hurt you
if you think it's a smoking gun and it's
not a smoking gun and you're touting
this as a smoking gun
that makes your entire presentation less
credible and it makes the average person
more inclined to believe the one who's
being accused and
the best example there's a a text chain
where deshawn watson asks the masseuse
if she's comfortable with the glute area
and apparently that's
that's the the the reason why that's oh
are you comfortable with the glute area
like that's some improper request
that's not an uncommon area
for an athlete to need to have a massage
sims talked about it yesterday before we
knew anything about these text messages
that the groin in the glute area
requires work especially for a football
player with all the
crouching and moving and and you need
those areas to be loosened up
and some masseuses are comfortable
some are not and he asked the question
are you comfortable if anything
that's a text message that his lawyer
would be releasing as proof that nothing
happened
so i was blown away when that's the one
when you go to tony
tony busby's in her uh what's it called
uh instagram
instagram page instaface profile
smash face as bill belichick would say
and uh
and you see that there you look at it
and you say
what do you what are you what are you
doing here unless you have a fundamental
misunderstanding of what goes on during
a massage
which he possibly does and which
possibly some of these novice masseuses
have
there's there's nothing there that shows
any wrongdoing
yeah that that's exactly what i thought
too because ostensibly he's asking for
consent there and i think that's what
everybody
would encourage you know you want to
make sure that everybody
is comfortable with the way things are
going to have to happen
in a professional athlete's massage and
i think if you look at that other
uh series of texts i mean the only thing
that's there
is i apologize if you felt uncomfortable
it wasn't my
intention now that could be interpreted
any number of ways but i think it's the
same sort of thing it's not necessarily
a smoking gun because what we don't know
is
at least at this point whether that
second
uh series of texts that was posted was
before
he sent the first series of texts
whether it was after
whether it was to the same person you
know it because they're
essentially on two different platforms
that first series looked like
they were instagram dms and that's these
are two different two different people
two different people yeah okay the the
second the second one yes
right the second one the second one was
and i didn't notice this at first and
this is my own
idiocy when it comes to instagram that
there can be a second page to it
when i clicked the button and saw the
second one it it refers to
an allegation that was made in the first
lawsuit where
there was a text message after the fact
where watson apologized and what he said
is sorry about you feeling uncomfortable
never were the intentions let me know if
you want to work in the future my
apologies
now again in the context of a massage
which is an inherently intimate act
did it and and there are certain things
that you need to have massaged and if
you're not comfortable ahead of time
and you and you find out during the
massage the person isn't comfortable
that that reasonably leads to that kind
of exchange so this isn't the classic
apology that you would point to
you know after a car accident oh they
apologize they must be at fault
no this is this is a reasonable in the
context
apology that would be made by someone
who needed an area massage that the
person providing the massage wasn't
comfortable providing it's it's that
simple
yes it is and so that's why
this as you were just saying it it's not
the smoking gun
that some might think it is just based
on what the context is
of a professional athlete's massage and
i think
that's important to remember now the
other part of that is
it it also doesn't prove that he didn't
do anything
right so there there's just sort of
nothing that we can definitively
say from these two uh
series of messages that desean watson
sent
allegedly to these young women so that
but if that's what you're touting
if that's what you're touting no but but
that what concerns me is
if that's the best you've got what are
you doing
what do you do why why are you why are
you
making this big reveal and acting like
it's a big deal
unless the unless he's just trying to
reduce our expectations
and then today at the press conference
there's going to be text messages that
are far more damning
but if this is consistent with what he's
going to reveal today
i look at it and i say that this isn't
what you think it
is and it is entirely possible
that uh tony busby has yet to develop
the expertise necessary to understand
what happens during the massage
of a professional athlete and i
guarantee you this number one
desean watson is not going to back down
desean watson will spend whatever money
is necessary to defend himself i think
the point of
a potential settlement is long gone even
if the plaintiffs at this point would
still want one
desean is girding for a fight he's hired
rusty harden who has represented people
like adrian peterson and roger clemens
and deshawn watson i believe as part of
the money that will be spent
on this on this defense will include
other people who have given him massages
people from the texans
expert witnesses on what this all means
and what happens during a massage
and how certain things are normal and
certain
activities uh are requested by
professional athletes
and specifically that desean watson
routinely has
massages in the areas that that
some may find uncomfortable and that
during the process of that massage there
may be
incidental contact with other things
that aren't part of the massage so again
like you said none of this means he's
innocent
but there's nothing that's been released
yet
that shows he's not and you know the
allegations in the complaint are just
that they will be subject
to efforts to prove that they're not
accurate
mistaken embellished fabricated whatever
but uh i come back to the fact that
there are nine
it's still not going to be easy for
deshaun watson
to prove that nine different people are
are are wrong but but here's where
there's a benefit miles
because it's one lawyer who's
representing all of them
and it's obvious from his social media
activity that this lawyer
has a desire to get to sean watson
if they can in just one of those nine
cases
just one expose a big lie
expose a smoking gun that goes the other
way
that causes all nine to crumble and the
first thing that i would do
if i was the lawyer representing desean
watson is i would go into court with a
motion to consolidate
all nine cases into one you don't want
nine different bites at the apple
you don't want nine different chances
you want all or nothing
one case let's go because then you only
have to
show that one is a complete and total
liar
if you can and again this is all part of
this legal strategy i'm not saying who's
right who's wrong
but if you get it all into one case if
one of those nine
doesn't hold up if one of those nine can
be proven to be lying you don't have to
prove potentially that the other eight
are
because the whole the whole thing is
tainted at that point
now one bad apple spoils the entire
bunch and and that's why
it is important i think from the legal
strategy standpoint
is to do exactly what you're saying i
mean if you're deshawn watson that you
basically
know that that's how you can
uh you can make yourself look the
absolute best
because if that is the case
where there is the big lie and you have
one
of these uh alleged victims who is not
in fact an alleged victim and you know
you
see all of these different things that
come about then
yes that is exactly how deshawn should
play this in terms of a legal strategy
because
that is exactly how he's probably going
to be seen best at least in the public
eye because when you're talking about
the nine
you're exactly right there's just and
you said it earlier in the segment you
know what is the over
under who knows but when you get to a
certain point
it's just by sheer numbers it's almost
hard to say well
wait a minute there must be something
going on here but
that doesn't necessarily have to be the
case just because
the quantity is up it doesn't
necessarily mean
that there is something there
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports